die SPD Gremien haben gerade begonnen
das SPD-Präsidium das geheimste Gremium
was ist bei der Partei gibt Saskia Essen
die umstrittene Vorsitzende ist zu
Beginn dieses Präsidiums auf Armin
Laschet losgegangen auf die Union und
hat kritisiert das ist dort ein Anspruch
gab überhaupt auf die
Regierungsbildung das sei angesichts von
über 8% Punkten Verlust nicht in Ordnung
sagt Saskia Essen und wir erleben ja das
parallel nur wenige Kilometer vom
Willy-Brandt-Haus entfernt im
Konrad-Adenauer-Haus genau diese Debatte
tobt um diesen regierungsanspruch den es
da gestern gegeben hat Armin Laschet das
habe ich vorhin berichtet hat das mehr
oder weniger wieder eingepackt aber
gleichzeitig hat Michael Kretschmer der
sachsen-anhaltinische Ministerpräsident
hatte Töne rausgehauen er hat gesagt die
grundtonalität war falsch gestern Abend
und er hat gesagt das der Wahlniederlage
nach außen ist Armin Laschet das gehöre
dazu daraufhin hat Armin Laschet gesagt
dass sei doch eh klar aber er will sich
halten er will drin bleiben er will zwar
nicht Fraktionschef werden das hat er
auch in diesem Gremium klar gemacht aber
er will Parteivorsitzender bleiben und
es gibt Aussagen auch von Olaf Scholz
die lese ich einmal vor was er dort
gerade genau im Präsidium gesagt hat
Olaf Scholz hat gesagt es war eine
großartige Leistung wir haben gezeigt
dass wir geschlossen sind nicht nur in
der Führung sondern in der ganzen Partei
die BürgerInnen haben angeschaut ob das
wirklich so ist das haben sie gesehen
wir haben es gelungen ein
zuversichtliches Programm zu haben ich
möchte dass die SPD die Partei der
anstehenden Modernisierung unseres
Landes ist und dann hat er die Punkte
genannt für die die SPD gewählt worden
sei und dann zu formulieren wir wollen
eine ampelregierung bilden mit Grünen
und FDP wir wollen eine Koalition bilden
die positive Ziele für die Zukunft hat
und dann es wird deutlich werden dass es
gut für Deutschland ist klare Ansage
hier endlich kann man was sagen weil
aber hinter verschlossenen Türen aber
wir hören das alles Kai zumindest merkt
man dass die SPD heute Morgen nach dem
kleinen Kater aufgewacht ist und gesehen
hat oh wir müssen ja immer noch darum
kämpfen dass wir dieses Kanzleramt
bekommen das wird uns nicht einfach
geschenkt weil wir erster werden und das
ist jetzt das direkte geheime
Aufeinandertreffen nur wenige Kilometer
entfernt voneinander das
Willy-Brandt-Haus hier in der
Kreuzberg in der Nähe und das
Konrad-Adenauer-Haus am Tiergarten das
trennt nicht viel und die beiden Gremien
diese beiden geheimgremien die Hämmern
aufeinander los
[Musik]